we are wrapping up another season of the
real housewives of potomac when you look
back
at the season that was what is the
lesson you are walking away from this
season with
oh my gosh
just give me the heavy hitters
wow you know what first of all i'll tell
you honestly
um
filming in a pandemic i really thought
that kovit was gonna like poo poo on our
season
my i guess lesson looking back on the
season is never underestimate these
potomac ladies i mean hello highest
rated season yet
what
yes i mean that's a miracle honestly
it's it's impressive it really is
spending all that time together has also
i think made tensions
that much more tense
you've had some moments with wendy this
season
after reunion where are we at better or
worse off than we were in season
you know i mean i hate to like really
give anything away but i
don't feel good about where we are
unfortunately i wasn't expecting that i
was actually expecting to go into the
reunion and come out with some
resolution and to go in with you know
people willing to hear each other out
maybe see things differently once you're
able to like watch the season and talk
it through she came in
not yeah not even attempting to listen
i felt like
during the season
she was making assumptions about
what happened and then i'm so i'm
thinking okay well once you watch the
show she'll realize like you know it
really wasn't what she was assuming and
and then so i was really surprised to
come into the reunion and it was like
the same it was like more of the same is
there a path forward do you think that
there could be something in the future
or does it feel like it's done done
you know at this point i will say the
ball is in her court
i didn't go into the reunion with you
know anger and being tense and being you
know like rude and stuff like that so
it's so at this point i'm kind of saying
to myself i know where i st i know where
i stand with her i did not walk away
feeling comfortable because
i walked away feeling worse
yikes we definitely are seeing a
different side to her which has
obviously been a topic of conversation
this season i feel like your personality
is slightly different i feel like the
wendy i met last year was not that loose
do you think she
gets it that she came off differently
this season
honestly from what i can see of
you know all of her
media interviews honestly i don't i
don't think she's going to ever say yes
you're right i
changed or you know what people are
saying about me is true i think she's
like trickling down on
everything that like we've seen she has
claimed
that you are the person who first told
her about the eddie cheating rumors
true or false well it wasn't that i was
like the first person to tell her i saw
it on
on the non-credible blog
her saying that is not like that's
that's not a smoking gun what i
expressed at that time was
you know i can't believe they're doing
this like why are they you know why are
they putting out stupid stuff like this
you know no not thinking that there was
any truth to it so right it was care and
concern from the jump for you yeah just
like girl i'm so like i'm sorry they're
attacking like that whatever like you
know like don't worry about it so when
we're in williamsburg
and it's literally almost three months
later and she's like yelling she's i
felt like i was being accused of
something what was said about eddie
don't worry if you want to know your
friend will tell you no i want to know
from you you're i want to know what
you're receiving as them talking about
your husband you won the moment so bad
girl
moment
moment it's like she wanted to assume
the worst in me and that i think is what
hurt me most about our friendship and
even with you know whatever giselle and
actually were talking about they weren't
attacking her family but she keeps going
on this
attacking my family attacking my husband
thing what you're not going to do let's
be very clear is you're not going to
play with my husband's name she's upset
about somebody coming for her
relationship and then to turn it on you
and
cut you so deep so fast out of nowhere i
think is pretty jarring it was it was
jarring and it was very telling in that
moment you're upset you're heated
whatever once you see
you know it things weren't really the
way that you thought they were
okay so why are you doubling and
trickling down in your media interviews
and continuing to put down my
relationship that's the part where i'm
stuck it's like one thing while we're
filming they're like doubling down
insulting people in their relationships
when i i've never said one bad thing
about her husband her relationship i
never talked about that rumor
between seasons five and six what was
your friendship like with her did it
seem fine up until this turn happened
while cameras were up absolutely you
know i would hope she would be one to
tell you that i was probably someone
that would check on her the most when it
came to
you know just dealing with
social media and trying to stay strong
and for her to just take everything that
i said
and
make it seem like i was coming from a
bad place it just said a lot to me and i
really feel like that's because she's
playing the game of like
she's over strategizing she's
overthinking she's playing this tv game
you know you know she changed her
appearance
the appearance thinks fine like that
yeah all the time but let's talk about
that because i feel like this
conversation around her changing
personality has been conflated with the
change in appearance can you clear up
those are two different conversations
essentially well
they are candace and i were talking on
the phone and in our conversation i said
candace i can't put my finger on it i
don't know what it is
but wendy feels so different to me
something is different she's changed
like but i can't put my finger on it you
know i i didn't have the words for it i
think the conversation got melded
together because it's you're kind of
wondering does one have to do with the
other i've i've seen more of your body
parts in the past month than i have the
entire time i've known you
yeah the difference is clearly i had my
boobs done i was kind of frustrated
because i think wendy got hung up on the
body you know the change in the body
talk which is kind of disappointing to
me because if someone if one of my
friends comes to me and says
hey i noticed some changes you know
you're you're acting differently your
personality is different you're behaving
differently i would be more concerned
about that
than being concerned about like what
you're saying about the change in the
way i'm dressing or the way or my
behavior like i i would be more like oh
my gosh like
you know let's talk about it why am i
making you feel like this like i don't
want you to feel that way that's
something i hadn't thought about that
she didn't give you the space to have
that conversation instead she was
defensive we saw that on the boat
incredibly defensive when mia came back
and misrepresented what you had said
downstairs
you're damn right i'm not the same
person i was a year ago and if she's the
same person she was a year ago then she
needs to change she needs a
[ __ ] ball and i think that
speaks a lot to just like our friendship
and how she viewed it it's like she was
so quick to throw an insult out at me i
wasn't even talking bad about her i feel
like i should always be able to
speak my mind with my friends and tell
them like if i'm noticing something
different like that's what friendship is
you tell your friends like hey
you know something's a little different
are you okay is it all good i just want
to make sure like you know you aren't
you know trying to be you know change
yourself because of social media like
whatever it might be but for her to just
be so defensive off of everything that
we would say
and to want to make it turn it into like
you know we're looking for a moment
we're being dramatic we're being mean
girls we're being bullies like i just
i don't i didn't get it i i i was very
disappointed they want to leave we don't
know where i mean even the whole like
when we
left the house
to go to a hotel
and she says oh they're just looking for
a moment
leaving in the middle of the night i
feel like they're trying to make a
moment we didn't bother anyone we didn't
inconvenience their trip at all
me straight to the ladies room this one
yeah i promise you if that was karen
that didn't have a bathroom she would
have showed some compassion she would
have understood if karen left the house
to go stay in a hotel 30 35 miles away
to be comfortable instead of saying that
karen was looking for a moment so it's
just like let's be fair here you know
i don't know i like i don't like i said
i don't feel good about where we are
like and unfortunately the reunion
didn't help let's circle back to reunion
nicki minaj showed
up to this thing and this was actually a
surprise to you guys you guys did not
know this was happening no it was a huge
surprise and bravo and production did a
great job of like
surprising us you know because i think
going in we always we all just like you
know in our minds like we got to make it
happen like you know nikki's going to be
there like but they really kind of like
took us off the scent
and
the surprise it was amazing it was
amazing it was so like i literally was
just like sitting
sitting on the couch like
how did i get here like
you know so it was one thing to already
be like on a real housewives show but i
was literally like okay now this is like
the biggest pinch me i think i actually
turned to like ashley or candace and i
was like i think it was ashley i was
like
are we here like i'm like pitching her
now i know who you were sitting next to
at the reunion oh yeah
candace told me that nikki quote read
you all for filth and like really went
in on somebody and candace said it is
not her
so who did she really go in on
i mean okay i think you're gonna have to
watch i'm not gonna be the one just but
no she definitely
it's funny like she asked questions that
like
you know i think some of the viewers are
going to be like thank you like you know
they were funny give me give me a tease
of one topic maybe she got into
she gets into the whole robin and
giselle thing candace told me that nicki
was pulling out stuff that like you guys
haven't even thought about in years what
surprised you the most you know like i
always knew
i knew that that nikki watched the show
because
she was following me on instagram in
season one i was like floored by that so
i also you know i was aware that she
she's not new to potomac you know
she she was just so familiar you know it
she felt it really literally felt like
she's worked she's worked on the show
although she's so familiar she's watched
it for years
it didn't feel like she had a favorite
it didn't feel like she was biased and i
appreciated that because you know
nowadays it's so easy to get swayed you
know
one side or the other
she says stuff where i'm like well thank
you like
coming from me i'm a bad guy but coming
from nicki minaj it's okay okay you
don't even mean it's like okay
is the person she really went in on on
your couch or the other couch
see i don't i feel like it could be home
it could be do you feel like it was an
equal opportunity
interrogation okay
okay i think some people have more
uncomfortable conversations than others
okay but i can't say honestly i wouldn't
pick one like i literally feel like it
came well we'll also see i hear she was
out there for a minute so i guess we'll
have to see what actually makes it to tv
too she was out there for a very long
time like hours
but she also is very like
slow in her she's thoughtful yes yes she
it's you know she's she wasn't like
quick hitting with the questions she was
like really slow with it very
intentional very deliberate and
sometimes would get into like
conversations you know she had to do her
little makeup checks and hair checks it
sounds like she understood the
assignment she came with her questions
followed the conversation where it went
after reunion do you see this whole
group coming back do you expect changes
i mean obviously you and wendy seem to
have unfinished business um what do you
what's your read on where this group
goes from here well i mean
the season is really successful i'm sure
the goal would be to try to get everyone
back to a good place
i'm not like a woe as me type person so
you know i'm just gonna deal with people
where they are not try to force anything
candice told me she left reunion more
confused than ever about mia what's your
vibe with mia it's not even um the stuff
on the show with me because i feel like
early on i figured out that about mia
like okay she's just going to be all
over the place yeah her social media has
been the wild wild west and she has
blamed it on a social media manager you
don't buy that okay no i don't i don't
buy that at all
at all i wish i could have like gotten
to her before she
before she put that out because the the
fans are smarter than that this is the
first time you're doing this you're
going to learn you're going to make
mistakes it is right
right yeah so i so i think her social
media got like made things worse for her
honestly than anything she said or did
on the show because on the show you saw
her you know even with what she you know
she came back and said well robin said
this and then she said oh well i'm sorry
if that's what i want
the whole text message thing too early
on was a whole
tone
so i said hi mia i'm quite taken aback
by your rude response with something
done to you that we are not aware of
yeah is this how you treat people who
are trying to get to know you what am i
missing
she says at gizelle since my message was
directed to you
i apologize if you felt like my response
was rude i was simply being direct
and what is the update on embellished
have we emailed macy's back robin
so yeah so i you know communicate with
the retailers the problem is retail is
you know they take a big chunk of your
money right
so that's kind of like
where i'm stuck so i have not you know
i'm still just e-commerce only i am
considering you know
uh retail
but i just don't know if it's going to
make sense for me because my hat my hats
aren't that expensive you know so it's
like if you're taking a big chunk of my
money i'm like
will you add a candle to the embellished
line
and would it be one wick to wick three
wick four
you know what no i will absolutely not
add a candle
i think the market is pretty saturated
um honestly i feel like on a show on a
when you have a platform that's very
visual such as a tv show
then your product should be visual you
know if it was me i would have done
something different but you know to each
their own
[Music]
[Music]